creuser des trous quelle que soit la
saison
ça réchauffe et ce jour là alors que
nous sommes en plein coeur de l'automne
il fait particulièrement chaud est ce
une chaleur anormale
est ce une chaleur due à l'activité
humaine ces chercheurs n'ont sont déjà
plus à ces questions là pour eux le
réchauffement climatique est un
phénomène inéluctable selon les
scénarios les plus répandues on
s'oriente vers des été plus chaud et
plus sec et d hiver qui serait
probablement plus humide
pour ces spécialistes de la forêt
l'enjeu est d'étudier dès aujourd'hui
l'adaptation des différentes espèces à
cette évolution
on étudie deux scénarios de gestion
qu'on a choisis en concertation avec
l'office national des forêts qui sont
réduction du nombre d'arbres et mettre
en mélange deux essence réduire le
nombre d'arbres s'est liée à l'hypothèse
que si on a moins d'arbres mais la forêt
va consommer moins d'eau puisque c'est
les arbres qui vont absorber le plus
doux c'est pas si simple que ça parce
que quand on ouvre le couvert la
végétation du sous-bois peut également
puiser de l'eau et parfois même
contrebalancer l'effet bénéfique
d'enlever un certain nombre drame
le deuxième scénario c'est m 2 essence
en mélange nous étudions le mélange
chêne sessile pin sylvestre
ce mélange entre le chêne le pain c'est
celui qu'on trouve dans la plupart des
forêts françaises celle d'orléans est
principalement peuplé par ces deux
espèces selon les zones on trouve des
andro le chêne est majoritaire dans
d'autres c'est le pain qui domine les
chercheurs de l'ird terre ont ainsi
déterminé 33 parcelle d'un demi-hectare
chacune présentant différentes densités
elles vont être scrutés pendant
plusieurs décennies pour voir laquelle
est la plus résistante taille des arbres
taux d'humidité qualité du sol tout est
étudié
même le nombre de racine par mètre carré
et pour ça c'est assez simple c'est
comme de jouer à la bataille navale
oui tout est trop 22 race in fine du g12
moyenne à grosses et ce sera tout 24 as
in fine du ger 1 de moyenne à bruce du
gr 1
chaque petite maille fait 10 cm de côté
par 10 cm de côté on compte le nombre de
racines de chaîne le nombre de racines
de pins et le nombre de racines de
fougères ou alors de molinie et ça nous
permet en fait de mieux comprendre
comment les racines vont se répartir
géographiquement dans le sol
chose qu'on peut pas voir si on l'ouvré
pas cette force alors pendant quelques
temps bien sûr les travaux
d'installation dérange un peu les
voisins comme ceux triton pas très
habitués à avoir de la visite beaucoup
plus souvent des salamandres à qui une
classique
les jaune et noir et très rarement les
tritons déjà par leur taille et leur
couleur qui sont beaucoup moins visible
donc il faut vraiment il tombait dessus
pour les observer une observation assez
rare une fois mis en place le dispositif
doit permettre de récolter des milliers
de données sans perturber
l'environnement
c'est dont le sous sol que sont
installés la plupart des instruments de
mesure donc ici ce qu'on installe ses
des sondes qui vont mesurer la teneur en
eau on va mesurer l'eau en volume
donc on va la mesure et à 20 à 40 est à
60 cm donc c'est à dire dans le sable au
niveau du plancher argileux et dans
l'argent et on va pouvoir comme ça
suivre tout au long de l'année
l'évolution de la teneur en eau et après
pouvoir caractérisé par exemple les
années de forte sécheresse
un stress hydrique la caractéristique de
la forêt d'orléans et ce qui présente un
horizon sable en surface c'est très
tendance pour ces fonds du sable
classique alors s'effrite facilement ses
traits drainant ça retient pelo et en
profondeur gît là puis quand elle est
sèche très dur
extrêmement compact qui également sec
très difficile pour les arbres être
puisée le sol cette couche d'argile
souterraine particulièrement sèche en
était capture l'eau l'hiver comme une
baignoire ce qui a pour effet de noyer
les racines quand elles n'en n'ont pas
besoin
le chêne a plus besoin d'eau au
printemps tandis que le pain lui et
sensibles à la sécheresse estivale
ces variations climatiques ont un impact
sur la croissance des arbres qu'on
observe aussi avec d'autres méthodes à
l'ancienne
c'est des petits appareils de mesure qui
nous permettent de venir mesurer la
croissance des arbres a pas de temps
réguliers au cours de l'année
c'est-à-dire convient les visiter tous
les quinze jours on peut faire une
mesure tous les quinze jours et voir si
l'arbre à a poussé ou rétrécies par
rapport aux visites précédentes parce
qu'ils peuvent rétrécir les armes
peuvent être réussir tout à fait par
exemple lors d'épisodes
de temps plus sec le lin va être capable
de diminuer la quantité d'eau qu'il a
dans ses cellules et donc ça se traduit
par un rétrécissement du tronc mais qui
est de l'ordre du dixième de millimètre
sur la circonférence tous les quinze
jours les chercheurs viennent en forêt
se connecter aux terminaux ou son
récolter toutes les données
il en profite aussi pour faire des
observations étudier l'impact du
changement climatique sur la forêt c'est
aussi s'intéresser à l'impact de la
faune et en particulier du gibier sur la
pousse des jeunes arbres dans cet espace
délimité par les piquets orange
chaque petit rameau et recenser d'une
visite à l'autre on mesure la croissance
des vivants et on compte les morts
c'était un pin sylvestre déjà il avait
déjà été observé puisqu'il a une
étiquette donc c'est un arbre que j'ai
déjà eu entre les mains il y a un nom à
l'époque il avait déjà subi un dommage
qu'on va entre apercevoir ici vous avez
les corses qui est blessé et boursouflé
et en fait ça c'est la signature d'un
frottis qui a été réalisé par un
chevreuil à chevreuil mâle alors le
chevreuil porte des bois est dans sa
période de reproduction il va chercher à
marquer son territoire et il va donc est
à la recherche d'individus de ce type là
qui ont une certaine rigidité une
certaine flexibilité et il va frotter
avec ses bois pour donc marquer son
territoire
et pour étudier plus précisément
l'interaction entre la croissance des
arbres
la pluviométrie la température et le
grand gibier
certaines parcelles ont été clôturés
protégée par un grillage
elle les chaînes et les pains sont plus
nombreux à survivre d'autres parcelles
offre une protection dite sélective
ces rondins bloquent l'accès des
chevreuils et dessert mais ils laissent
passer les sangliers pour mieux étudier
leurs impacts sur le milieu
le sanglier en faible densité lui peut
avoir un effet positif c'est un animal
qui cherche qui fuit soeur c'est à dire
qu'il va rechercher sa nourriture dans
le sol avec son gros il fait ce qu'on
appelle des beauty va rechercher des
verts des fruits forestiers des glandes
et fun donc il va consommer ses fruits
forestiers mais en en consommant il en
enfouis d'autres ce qui fait que le
chêne peut être favorisé par exemple par
le sanglier en terme donc de germination
des glands si évidemment il ya trop de
sangliers à tous les glands seront
consommés ou les petits chênes qui
commencent à pousser vont être arrachés
vous déchausser par le sanglier donc ce
qu'on cherche à savoir si voilà les
effets imputable à chaque espèce en
fonction donc le niveau de densité plus
ou moins important
les chercheurs de l'ird téa ne
s'intéresse pas qu'aux gibier c'est
l'ensemble de la faune présente dans le
milieu forestier qui était étudié
jusqu'au coléoptères qu'il ya des taches
le changement climatique aura un effet
sur la biodiversité mais pour évaluer
les changements qui auront lieu dans le
long terme il faut déjà recensé les
espèces présentes aujourd'hui en termes
de diversité
on a pu déjà identifié une centaine
d'espèces dont une espèce de mousse et
pour la première fois répertoriée dans
la région donc c'est un fait est ce
qu'elle est intéressante
il s'avère que cette espèce au delà
d'être la première répertoriés
pourraient être liés au changement
climatique
c'est ce que les britanniques nos
voisins britanniques ont pu mettre en
évidence et qu' ils ont étudié cette
mousse de la connaissent bien ils ont
répertorié dans certains endroits et
voit que cette son aire de répartition
s'étale en fonction de l'augmentation de
la température donc liés au changement
climatique
il est très pro fort probable que dans
notre cas cette espèce là soient
arrivées ou en tout cas ça soit plus
importante dans la forêt d'orléans dû à
cette augmentation de température qu'on
a pu également observer
cette mousse représente-t-elle une
richesse pour la biodiversité ou au
contraire constitue-t-elle une menace
pour le milieu forestier
va-t-elle se développer s'agit-il des
prémices d'une invasion massive venus de
l'étranger
les chaînes vont ils tous mourir et les
sangliers avec toutes les questions
posées vont pouvoir trouver une réponse
grâce à l'observatoire du réchauffement
climatique mais il faudra attendre
quelques années avant la publication des
premières études